EXAMPLE IS IMPORTANT.
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN.
AS WE MENTIONED, BREAKING
TONIGHT AT THE TOP, WE ARE
GIVING YOU THE FIRST LOOK AT
TONIGHT AT NEW FOX POLLS FOR
SEVERAL BATTLEGROUND STATES.
NOT GOOD NEWS FOR THE PRESIDENT
IN THESE POLLS, JOE BIDEN LEADS
IN PENNSYLVANIA 50-39, THE
PRESIDENT HAS LOST THREE POINTS
SINCE APRIL AND IN 2016
CANDIDATE TRUMP WON BY LESS THAN
A PERCENTAGE POINT.
IN MICHIGAN, THE MARGIN IS NINE,
A ONE POINT GAIN AGAIN FOR BIDEN
AND IN MINNESOTA, BIDEN IS UP 13
POINTS, 51-38.
DONALD TRUMP LOST THAT STATE IN
2016 BY 1.5% TO HILLARY CLINTON.
THE TWO MEN WHO WILL BE AT THE
TOP OF THE TICKET IN NOVEMBER
ARE SPENDING THIS WEEK ARGUING
OVER RACISM.
JOE BIDEN SAYS PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS THE FIRST RACIST ELECTED TO
THE TOP JOB, THE PRESIDENT SAID
THAT’S AN AFFRONT TO
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IS POINTING BACK TO
JOE BIDEN’S PAST COMMENTS.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY HAS
THE LATEST.
>> JOE BIDEN BELIEVES 45 IS A
FIRST.
>> WE’VE HAD RACISTS AND THEY’VE
TRIED TO GET ELECTED
PRESIDENT AND HE’S THE FIRST ONE
WHO HAS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS THIS IS
AN INSULT TO THE INTELLIGENCE OF
BLACK VOTERS AND HE’S TRYING TO
ADD HISTORICAL CONTEXT.
>> I’VE DONE MORE FOR BLACK
AMERICANS THAN ANYBODY WITH THE
POSSIBLE EXCEPTION OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
>> 12 U.S. PRESIDENTS AT SOME
POINT OWNED, WOODROW WILSON WAS
JUST STRIPPED FROM PRINCETON FOR
HIS SEGREGATIONIST POLICIES AND
ANDREW JACKSON IS SET TO BE
REPLACED ON THE $20 BILL AFTER
HIS HISTORY OF MISTREATING AND
NATIVE AMERICANS BUT BIDEN
INSIST TRUMP IS THE FIRST
RACIST.
>> THE WAY HE PETS PEOPLE
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER IS ALL
DESIGNED TO DIVIDE THE COUNTRY,
DIVIDE PEOPLE.
>> IF THERE’S ONE BIDEN ATTACK
ON PEOPLE THAT HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT SINCE DAY ONE, IT’S
BEEN THIS.
THE CENTRAL THEME OF HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT VIDEO WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S RESPONSE TO
DEADLY RACE RIOTS IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
>> HE SAID THERE WERE "VERY FINE
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES."
VERY FINE PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES.
>> REGISTERED VOTERS TRUST BIDEN
OVER TRUMP IN EVERY ISSUE IN
BATTLEGROUND MINNESOTA BUT TRUMP
ISBIDENIS HOPING TO HOLD HIS OVE
LEAD WITH HELP FROM HIS OWN
BOSS.
>> WHAT KIND OF VALUES ARE YOU
HOPING TO LEAD TO?
>> BINGO.
>> IT APPEARS HE DID THIS ONE